>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: And Welcome,
welcome to the Library of Congress.
Welcome to the African
Middle East division.
I'm Mary-Jane Deeb,
chief of the division
and I can't tell you how happy I
am to see or hear what promises
to be a very exciting program.
Today this division is
hosting Dr. Fereydoun Ala.
And it's very special.
And it's different from many of
the other programs we've had.
We always have people who are
great scholars and historians.
Who are specialists
in different fields.
But we rarely have, and
almost never in fact,
have a great man of science.
And today we have brought
to the Library really a major
figure in medicine and science.
But a very modest person or so who
has sent just a little paragraph
on his bio, and so I had to go
online to find more about him
to be able to speak more
extensively about him.
But before I go into
the introduction,
I want to say something
about this division.
We always do, this
program is be webcast.
And so I have to do a little
commercial about our division.
And this is a division which is
responsible for serving, collecting,
serving the publications
from 78 different countries.
In the content of Africa, in the
Middle East, and central Asia.
And it includes three
sections, the Hebraic section,
which deals with Hebraic
and Judaic worldwide.
The Near East section, which is one
of the most expansionist sections
which goes from Morocco through
the Arab world, Iran, Turkey,
central Asia, the [inaudible],
and section is also responsible
for publications that
go as far as China.
And then Africa, which is the
entire subcontinent of Africa.
Our specialists speak the
languages, know the culture,
often come from those countries,
and we do different things.
Not only do we collect,
serve those collections
to our scholars, but we do exhibits.
We do displays.
We have, we show films.
We have music entertainment.
We provide different ways to present
those countries, their languages,
their culture, to the public.
Iran is one of the
most important regions.
Iran and beyond the
Iranian world where Persian,
the Persian language is spoken.
And it's part of the culture.
Is one of the pillars of
the Near East section.
We have a wonderful
specialist, [inaudible],
who has been responsible for
expanding the collection,
for making the first totally...
Persian exhibit a couple of years
ago and many of you were there.
It was hundred years
of the Persian book.
And he has brought great scholars.
But Dr. Fereydoun is very special.
And I'm going to read
to you some of the...
achievements that he's, that
his whole career is filled with.
So Dr. Ala started in Iran.
He went to Dabestane Nezami primary
school, he went to Laraziste school,
he went to the Community
School in English,
then he went to Harrow in England.
And the Milton Academy.
And he went to Harvard, where
he took a degree in history.
He seems not to mention
the historian in him
but we have brought
the historian back.
He was then admitted to the
Edinburgh University school
of medicine in Scotland, where
he obtained his medical degree,
that interned at the
Edinburgh Royal Infirmary
where he received a
Wellcome Trust research grant
under Professor Ronald Girdwood
when he investigated
megaloblastic anaemias associated
with gastrointestinal malabsorption.
He passed examination for membership
of the Royal College of Physicians,
both internal medicine and
Hematology, and he became a fellow
of the Royal College of
Physicians and a follow
of the Royal College
of Pathologists.
He returned to Iran soon after
his father, Hossein Ala died.
He was appointed assistant professor
at the Tehran University
School of Medicine.
And was instrumental in established
the first clinical hematology
department in Iran equipped with
its own modern laboratories.
He also established
a mitosis laboratory
to diagnose inherited blood
coagulation disorders,
such as hemophilia and
von Willebrands disease.
Another first was the introduction
of hepatitis B surface
antigen testing.
Hepatitis B was a common cause
of chronic liver disease in Iran.
Most particularly among
hemophiliacs.
In 1971, Dr. Ala organized
the seventh congress
of the World Federation
of Hemophilia in Tehran.
The first such meeting held
outside Europe and the Americas.
The proceedings of the meetings
were edited by F. Ala and published
by Eleviers Excepta
Medica in Amsterdam in '73.
In 1972, Dr. Ala proposed the
creation of a centralized,
state-funded national blood service
for the recruitment of healthy,
voluntary non-immune related donors
and the subsequent collection,
testing, and processing
and distribution of blood
and blood products for hospitals
free of charge in accordance
with modern technical
and ethical standards.
The object was to make these vital
services out of the commercialism
of the marketplace and bring them
into the realm of altruism
and science.
The Iranian National Blood
Transfusion Service was established
in 1974 and remains the
best developed service
in the eastern Mediterranean region
and has recently been nominated the
Regional World Health Organization
Collaborating Center
for Blood Transfusion.
Dr. Ala became a member of
the World Health Organization
for the Eastern Mediterranean
and Adversary Committee
on Medical Research in 1979
as well as a member of the
WHO Expert Adversary Panel on Blood
Products and Related Substances.
In 1981, Dr. Ala moved
from Iran to the UK
and was appointed medical director
of the National Blood Service,
West Midlands Region, he was
also appointed senior lecturer
at the Birmingham University Medical
Faculty, Consultant Hematologist
at the Queen Elizabeth Hospital.
And he was appointed two
different organizations.
His appointment as Councillor
to the International Society
of Blood Transfusion
was renewed in 1998.
And he was the co-editor
of "Transfusion Today,"
the ISBT Journal.
During this period, he acted
as WHO Short-term Consultant
on blood transfusion in Byelorussia,
Cyprus, Djibouti, Egypt, India,
Jordan, Kazakhstan,
Kyrgyzstan, Lebanon, Pakistan,
Syria, Tajikistan, and so on.
In 1999, Dr. Ala returned to Iran
to organization the biannual WOH
East Mediterranean Blood Transfusion
Directive meeting in Tehran.
He has spent a significant
part of this year working
on the newfound Iranian
Comprehensive Hemophilia Care Center
at the Iranian Hemophilia Society
in 2001, dedicated diagnosis
and management of inherited
[inaudible] disease.
And has been affiliated
with World Hemophilia.
Anyway, why did we invite him?
He's such a great scientist
and we have a National Library
because he also is a historian.
And he's going to say no, but he is.
He has written.
And Dr. Fereydoun Ala is also
the son of the late Hossein Ala,
diplomat, sometime minister of
court, and prime minister of Iran.
He is the grandson of
Mohammad-Ali Ala' oh-Salteneh,
foreign minister and prime minister.
His maternal grandfather was
Abolqasem Khan Gharagozlou Naser
ol-Molk, who was regent while
Ahmad Shah Qajar was still a minor.
He has brought to the library
some of the translations
of his grandfather, who was, who
translated Shakespeare and some
of Shakespeare's plays for
the first time in Persian.
And these are precious
translation that we hold.
Very, very important.
And it is also important that
we bring the history of Iran
to the American public so that
they understand the whole span,
the complexity of Iranian history.
We just had a major
conference on the [inaudible].
We brought scholars from all over
the United States to speak about it.
And the emphasis of this division is
to bring the culture, the history,
the people, to the forefront.
So that Americans and others
understand that the history
of the country is made up of many,
many stages of many people
and it extremely rich.
And we know that Dr. Ala is going
to give us another dimension,
which we have not talked about.
And it in his talk that we are
very much looking forward to learn
about that period of Persian
history through his own family.
So I know I've talked a great deal,
but I'm going to stop now
and introduce Dr. Ala.
[ Applause ]
>> Fereydoun Ala: Well first and
foremost, Welcome first of all.
I'm overwhelmed by
this large audience.
First and foremost, I must thank Dr.
Deeb and Dr. Dinavari very warmly
for the privilege of
giving this talk today,
although I have absolutely no claim
to being a scholar of Qajar history,
as the poster announcing
my talk indulgently claims.
This is a rather personal,
rambling family memoire,
which nevertheless does span
both Qajar and Pahlavi eras,
and which I hope will be
of some interest to you.
My maternal family, of
the Qaragozlou tribe,
originated as a section of the
Qara-qoyunlou (the Black Sheep)
at the mouth of the Syr Darya
River (inaudioble) in Turkestan,
and was probably settled in Hamadan,
the ancient Ecbatana of the Medes,
by Amir Teymour Gourkani
(Tamerlane),
sometime towards the
end of the 14th Century.
This was the founder of the
Teymourid Dynasty - great warriors
and patrons of the arts, and rulers
of what is today, Iran, Afghanistan,
Tajikistan and Uzbekistan.
It was his descendant Babur,
who established the brilliant 16th
Century Mughal Dynasty in India.
My oldest known maternal ancestor,
Mohammad Hossein Khan Qaragozlou,
governor of Luistan?,
second from the right,
with the white beard) grandfather
of my great, great grandfather,
was something of a king-maker,
helping Fath-Ali Shah
to the Qajar throne
in the 18th Century.
The family of my paternal
grandfather,
Mohammad Ali Khan Ala'o-Saltaneh,
was also of Central
Asian extraction.
It is thought that the family was
descended from Uzun (tall) Hassan
of the Aq-qoyunlou (another
Oghuz Turcoman tribal federation
which ruled in present-day Iraq,
Turkey, Azarbaijan and Armenia -
the White Sheep, who were the
precursors of the Safavid Dynasty),
a great ally of 15th Century
Venice against the Ottoman Turks,
who married Despina Khatoun,
daughter of the last
Komnenius Byzantine Emperor.
One's heart goes out to Despina,
sent away to a barbarian prince
from her sophisticated,
luxurious home in Constantinople -
a last-ditch alliance to save
the once-great Byzantium,
as it crumbled before Ottoman
onslaughts, and finally foundered
in 1453, when Mohammad the
Conqueror took the city by storm.
Mohammad Ali Khan's father was
Mirza Ibrahim Khan, from an old
and prominent Azarbaijani
family, who was a graduate
of the Military School In
Tabriz, founded in 1808
by the French General de Gardane,
the envoy of Napoleon Bonaparte,
sent to train Persians in
the arts of modern warfare -
a part of Bonaparte's grand design
going far beyond the confines
of Europe, to exploit British
vulnerabilities in India,
and to foil Russian
ambitions in the region.
Ibrahim Khan was subsequently
appointed Aide-de-Camp
(Adjudan-bashi) to Fath-Ali
Shah's fourth son (one
of his 108 offspring!),
the combative Crown
Prince Abbas Mirza Qajar.
Later, as Consul-General in Baghdad,
Ibrahim Khan became a close friend
of the influential political figure
and writer, Majd ol-Molk Sinaki,
one of whose daughters was soon
to marry Ibrahim Khan's only son,
Mohammad Ali Khan, my grandfather.
My paternal great grandfather, Mirza
Mohammad Khan Majd ol-Molk Sinaki,
whom I've mentioned, must rank
among the most influential,
reform-minded members of the
social elite during the reign
of Naser ed-Din Shah Qajar,
well before the Constitutional
Revolution of 1906.
His hand-written, satiric
manifesto inveighing
against the prevailing Court
culture of corruption, patronage
and hand-outs; the cruelty and
self-seeking, backward nature
of society, was the first among
such protests at the time.
It could not appear in
print, for obvious reasons,
and was covertly circulated,
hand-to-hand among the most
influential members of society.
This was long before 'shab-namehs'
(literally night letters of protest)
or Malkam Khan's influential
newspaper "Qanun",
promoting modernity,
constitutional government
and limitation of royal power.
My father Hossein, was
born in Tiflis in 1882,
while his father Mohammad Ali
Khan was Persian Consul-General
in the Caucasus.
His mother, one of five
daughters of Majd ol-Molk Sinaki,
was Homa Khanom, titled
Azemat od-Dowleh,
a sister to the one-time
Grand Vizier Amin od-Dowleh,
and aunt of two future Prime
Ministers, Vosouq od-Dowleh
and his brother Qavam os-Saltaneh.
And here is a sketch by
my father of his mother.
Late in the summer of 1889, Naser
ed-Din Shah visited Tibilisi
on his way back from his third
European tour, and was entertained
by Mohammad Ali Khan, whose three
eldest offspring greeted the Shah
in fluent French and English -
an unusual accomplishment among
young Iranians, at the time.
This proved to be a crucial visit,
as the Shah was so impressed
by the hospitality and
competence of his host,
that he granted him the title
of Prince Ala'os-Saltaneh,
and soon after appointed
him Minister Plenipotentiary
to the Court of St. James, in
place of Mirza Malkam Khan,
who had held the post for
the previous thirteen years.
Although his mother Homa
Khanom, decided to return to Iran
with her youngest son Jamshid
(who was a bit of a mother's boy),
Hossein and his older brothers,
accompanied their father
to England in 1890.
Hossein was sent to Westminster
School as a day student,
but he also received the
ministrations of parades of tutors.
Hossein was a gifted cartoonist,
who drew often irreverent sketches
of the dignitaries visiting
his father in his spare time.
Indeed, it is unlikely that,
apart from Naser ed-Din Shah (here's
a sketch by Naser, a portrait of one
of the courtiers) and his brother
Ezz ed-Dowleh's often excellent
drawings and water-colours,
there were any other contemporary
artists producing drawings
or caricatures of the
social elite at the time.
This is a rather unkind
sketch by my father
of Zahra Khanom Taj os-Saltaneh,
daughter of Naser ed-Din Shah,
showing off her magnificent
embonpoint.
Zahra Khanom wrote a very frank
memoire, a vivid, first-hand account
of the Shah's intimate life and
his harem, and the corruption
and dissipation of
the members of Court.
In spite of being brought up
be wet-nurses and servants
in the stifling gilded
cage of royal privilege,
she became an unexpectedly
liberal-minded,
well informed individual,
familiar with the writings
of Jean-Jacques Rousseau,
Victor Hugo and Cervantes;
with European political
philosophy, the French Revolution,
and the policies of leading
contemporary statesmen,
such as Bismarck.
She was considered to be one of the
most beautiful women of her day,
and was an accomplished
lutenist and piano player,
much sought after by
Court suitors and poets.
In her memoire, she
is highly critical
of the pleasure-seeking Shahs,
particularly her brother,
Mozaffar ed-Din Shah, who do nothing
to improve the lot of their people,
or to foster the progress
of their backward country,
while indulging themselves in
useless and expensive trips
to Europe with a large entourage,
funded by vast loans
from the Russians.
After leaving Westminster School
in July 1900, Hossein qualified
in London, as a Barrister
at the Inner Temple,
like his eldest brother
Mehdi, and was called
to the Bar in November 1906.
(Here's another sketch by my father
showing the senior judge at the top
in what was called
the full bottomed wig.
And then Mehdi and himself
at the bottom.). Ala'os-Saltaneh
was nominated as Minister
for Foreign Affairs soon after
his return to Iran at the outset
of the Constitutional Revolution,
and designated Hossein
as his chef de cabinet .
In 1917, Mohammad Ali Khan Ala'
os-Saltaneh became Prime Minister,
but retained the portfolio
of the Foreign Ministry,
which had effectively
been administered
by Hossein (now titled
Mo'in ol-Vezareh)
for almost ten years.As a Foreign
Minister constantly brow-beaten
and bullied by either Russian or
British envoys, each vying for
yet further privileges
and concessions,
Mohammad Ali Khan perfected a most
effective 'stone-walling' expedient
for temporizing and
avoiding confrontation
with representatives
of these super-powers.
When faced with their
impossible demands,
he would simply feign deep
sleep in his ministerial chair.
The diplomat would sit, clearing
his throat from time-to-time,
in the hope that His
Excellency would wake.
Eventually, exasperated, he
tip-toed out of the room,
and the matter would be deferred
to some indefinite future -
the last refuge of a weak
and impotent government.
In 1919, Ala attended the
Paris Peace Treaty Conference,
as a member of the
Iranian delegation,
which included Moshaver
ol-Mamalek, the Foreign Minister,
and Zoka' ol-Molk Foroughi.
After World War I Iran,
which had suffered more
than any other non-belligerent
country, sought redress.
Heartened by Woodrow Wilson's
impossibly utopian ideas,
asserting the rights of small
nations, Iran even dared
to hope that, now that
the invading Russian
and Ottoman empires had ceased to
exist, the provinces of Azarbaijan,
Georgia and Armenia, which had
been lost to the Russians by force
of arms, might be regained.
The delegation unfortunately
failed to be officially recognized,
despite America's sympathetic
support,
due to Lord Curzon's machinations.
Indeed, what passed for the
Iranian government at the time,
ignored their increasingly desperate
telegraphic pleas for instructions
and funding, leaving
them marooned in Paris
with little sustenance
but macaroons and tea.
In 1920, just before Reza Khan's
coup d'etat of February 1921,
Hossein Ala was appointed
as Minister to Spain -
his first diplomatic post abroad.
There is still a fading studio
photograph of him lounging
on a couch in oriental costume,
smoking a hookah at
the Alhambra Palace.
Alas, I don't have it here.
The period between 1921 and
1933 represented a high-point
in Reza Khan, later Reza
Shah's twenty-year reign,
which ended so abruptly in 1941.
This was a period of extraordinarily
rapid change, authoritarian reform
and modernization, largely supported
by most sectors of society,
but for the clergy of course.
To the intelligentsia, it
represented a restoration
of national dignity, and an end
to the humiliation, fragmentation,
chaos and supine passivity of
the Qajar period, when Iran,
although nominally independent,
had become a mere buffer,
between the British
and Russian empires.
Like Mustapha Kamal Ataturk's
regime in Turkey, all the apparatus
of a modern state was laid
down during those few years.
Reza Shah's most controversial
measure was probably the
emancipation and forcible
unveiling of women (kashfe hejab),
which caused as much
dismay and resentment
as Peter the Great's arbitrary
decree banning beards among the
Russian boyars.
Not everyone was able
to accept this edict.
Indeed, traditional women in
families of modest means felt unable
to leave the house in
order to go shopping,
or attend the hammam
(the bath-house),
and resorted to the most
ingenious strategies in order
to by-pass the unveiling rule.
Some adopted the hazardous policy
of walking across the flat roofs
of neighbouring houses at night.
In one family, it was related
that the ladies of the household,
climbed into large sacks, which were
transported under cover of darkness
to the local hammam
in a wheel-barrow,
in order to escape the
attention of the police.
It was not until after
the early 1930s,
that Reza Shah's hitherto benign
and dynamic dictatorship became
increasingly absolute, repressive
and harsh, alienating
the political elite,
and losing the support
of the public.
One of Reza Shah's very
first programmes was
to establish the authority
of the state throughout Iran,
and to put down rebellious
tribal uprisings.
Having successfully dealt with
the political danger posed
by these tribal confederations, he
proceeded to a less judicious policy
of forcibly settling the
nomadic pastoral tribes,
banning the traditional seasonal
transhumance, and endeavouring
to turn nomads into
sedentary agriculturalists.
The ruthless enforcement
of this poorly thought-out,
coercive policy aimed at
changing an entire way of life,
led to considerable
hardship, loss of livestock
and impoverishment among the tribes.
Further to the detriment
of the pastoral way of life
and the influence and social
structure of the tribes,
the great khans and tribal
leaders, gradually became alienated
from their own peoples; migrated to
the capital, and instead of acting
as advocates of their tribes,
adopted dissolute urban ways,
facilitating Reza Shah's dominion,
just as Louis XIV was able
to draw the teeth of his
provincial grandees, by drawing them
into a futile, ceremonial
existence at Versailles.
In 1921, Mirza Hossein
Khan Ala was appointed
as Minister Plenipotentiary
to Washington DC,
where he made every effort to awaken
American interest in Persian history
and culture, as well as the
opportunities it presented
for US investment, following
the Constitutional Revolution,
the abolition of the Qajar
dynasty, and the accession
of Reza Shah Pahlavi to the throne.
To this end he traveled tirelessly
all over the United States,
delivering lectures
about modern Iran
and her ancient historical past, to
universities, business associations,
political and press clubs.
His cardinal objective however,
was to negotiate with Standard Oil
of New Jersey and Sinclair, for
an alternative oil agreement,
more favourable to Iranian interests
than the dreadful 1901 D'Arcy
agreement with the British and,
despite the profoundly depressed
financial markets throughout Europe
and the United States,
to obtain a national loan
which would enable
the new government
to undertake desperately
needed reform and development.
Another important task was
the recruitment of a financial
and taxation expert with
the help of Morgan Shuster,
a much-admired American
idealist, and friend of Iran,
who had been Administrator
of Finance a decade before,
Dr. Millspaugh, trained
as an economist,
was formally appointed
to the task in 1922.
Alas, the tragic murder of Major
Robert Imbrie, the US Vice-Consul
in Tehran, by a fanatical mob
in 1924, put an end to any hopes
of consummating a deal with
American oil companies.
The diplomatic colleagues of Hossein
Ala in Washington, Abdollah Entezam
and Soltan Mahmoud Amerie,
were also bachelors,
and they all lived
together at the Legation,
in the interests of economy.
They recalled with wry humour
that His Excellency was a stickler
for punctuality and discipline.
If they turned up late for work,
he would ostentatiously
consult his pocket watch,
murmuring that it must
be running fast.
When the junior Attaches
wanted a night
out with an American girl-friend,
they would leave a
ground-floor window off the latch,
so that they could creep in late,
without attracting the
Minister's opprobrium.
In September 1927, Hossein
Ala married Fatemeh,
daughter of Abolqassem Khan
Qaragozlou Naser ol-Molk,
formerly Prime Minister and later
Regent, between 1910 and 1914,
while Ahmad Mirza was still a minor.
Abolqasem Khan was
among the first Moslems
and certainly the first Iranian
to attend Oxford University
at Balliol College, where his
youngest son Hossein-Ali followed
him many years later.
Naser ol-Molk only reluctantly
allowed his only daughter to marry,
for she ran his large household
smoothly and with an iron hand.
After his four-year
tenure as Regent,
while the Crown Prince
was still a minor,
Abolqasem Khan organized the
coronation of Soltan Ahmad Shah
in 1914, left public life for
good, and departed for Europe.
While in London one
evening, and in the course
of a wide-ranging conversation
with a number of close friends,
the discussion touched
upon William Shakespeare.
One of those present, held
that to translate the works
of this celebrated
poet and playwright
into Persian was an impossible task;
that the genius of the two languages
and the underlying cultures
of the two countries were
simply too different.
Abolqasem Khan disagreed,
and to prove his point,
he began to translate a
few lines from Othello,
a play which he had
chosen entirely at random.
This is a painting by Kamal
ol-Molk by the way of Naser ol-Molk.
Thus, in his retirement, it was an
evening's light-hearted literary
conversation which led him
to translate the entire play,
followed a few years later, by
his translation of 'The Merchant
of Venice', which he
copied out in 1917
after several revisions,
in his own fine hand.
The final version was
expertly bound and illustrated
with little water-colour vignettes,
by his daughter Fatemeh, my mother.
And this is the cover of the 'The
Merchant of Venice' printed in Iran
but includes one of the water
colors that I mentioned.
There is a widespread and
unjust public perception
that translation is
not a creative process.
These magisterial translations
of Shakespeare,
clearly demonstrate the opposite.
Quite apart from the considerable
merits of the original plays,
the sheer elegance, freshness
and simplicity of these rendering
into Persian, marks them as ageless
"belles-lettres" in their own right.
While the language employed
over a thousand years ago
by the Persian poets Roudaki
or Ferdowsi has remained
entirely current and accessible
to present-day readers in Iran,
the English language has evolved
and changed radically in the 450
years since Shakespeare's time,
and calls for special study.
Words and expressions have either
acquired a different meaning,
or have fallen into disuse over
the years, and the large number
of classical or biblical
allusions utilized by Shakespeare,
compound the difficulties
of the translator.
Only an exceptionally
profound mastery of Persian,
as well as the complex nuances
of Shakespeare's language could
have produced the clarity and beauty
of Abolqasem Khan's prose -
qualities not normally associated
with an active political career.
Abolqasem Khan Qaragozlou
was born in Sheverin,
near Hamadan, in July 1856.
Even as a child, he was passionate
about acquiring knowledge,
and he spent his time as a youth,
learning all that could be learned
in those days, such as philosophy,
Arabic, mathematics, syntax,
Islamic jurisprudence (Fiqh), and no
doubt a little French and English.
Later, he came to Tehran where he
had the benefit of being taught
by the foremost teachers of the
day - Mirza Jelveh, a philosopher,
and Mirza Seyed Mohammad-Ali
Qa'eni, a prominent mathematician.
Indeed, he attained
the status of 'ejtehad'
in Islamic jurisprudence
and theology.
His father Ahmad Khan
Sartip, died relatively young,
and it was his grandfather Mahmoud
Khan Naser ol-Molk Farmanfarma
who brought him up.
Mahmoud Khan noticed his
grandson's aptitude and zeal
for acquiring knowledge, and
having perceived these qualities,
he requested Naser ed-Din Shah
(whom he was to accompany to Europe
on his second journey abroad in
1878), to permit his grandson
to travel with them to Europe
in order to learn English,
so that he could translate
the foreign newspapers
for the Shah in the future.
This is a painting
actually of Mahmoud Khan
when he was minister in London.
Abolqassem was already 22
when he reached London,
and he was therefore much too
old to go to Public School.
Instead, Mirza Malkam Khan Nazem
od-Dowleh, an ardent nationalist,
and one of the fathers
of the Iranian Constitutional
Revolution movement,
who longed for a modernized Iran,
and had been the Iranian Minister
in London since 1873,
was charged with the task
of finding him a tutor, and acting
as the young man's guardian,
while he was in England.
The tutor agreed to provide
tuition, board and lodging
for one Pound Sterling a day.
Mahmoud Khan had arranged that his
grandson should receive 300 Pounds a
year, so that he was not only
65 Pounds short in the year,
but he could only allow
himself a very frugal life.
By working sixteen hours a day
for a very austere six months,
Abolqasem was able to master
English, Greek and Latin,
in order to gain entry to
Balliol College at Oxford in 1879.
Balliol was then at
the height of its fame,
with the remarkable
Reverend Jowett as Master,
who took an immediate liking to him.
He was the first specimen
of a Persian (and one
of the first Moslems) to
be seen at the University,
and the Master guided
him through his studies.
Rather than taking
an Honours degree,
which would have confined
him to one subject,
he determined to acquire knowledge
in as varied a number of subjects
as he could possibly manage.
Thus, not only did he devote
himself to perfecting his English,
but he dedicated himself so
thoroughly to Greek and Latin,
that he could translate
Plato or Thucydides as easily
as he could read Shakespeare,
Virgil or Tacitus,
many years after he
left the College.
He had mastered them so fluently
that he could recite Euripides'
Medea in Persian by simply glancing
at the Greek text, when he retired
from public life forty years later.
In the past, most particularly in
the East, knowledge was considered
to be comprehensive and indivisible,
as it was in scholastic
times a hundred years before.
If one pretended to knowledge,
one had to know Arabic, exegesis,
jurisprudence, prosody,
philosophy, mathematics,
medicine, cosmology and music.
When asked to explain the
movements of the heavenly bodies,
one could not very well say that he
had only studied political economy.
Jowett's regard for Abolqassem Khan
was such that he often invited him
to his famed Sunday evening
suppers at the Master's Lodge,
which were always attended by the
foremost personalities of the time.
He recalled meeting
Swinburne, Tennyson,
and many of the well-known
statesmen and writers of the day.
He remembered Oscar Wilde as well,
but those with whom he kept a
lifelong friendship were Sir Cecil
Spring-Rice, Lord Grey, and most
particularly Lord George Curzon,
the future Foreign Secretary.
Abolqasem Khan's nickname Abol
Curs'im Can was a wry tribute
by his fellow undergraduates
to his mental stamina
and academic achievements,
who said of him:
"There's nothing Abol Curs'im can't"
Of course, the most famous limerick
from Balliol was about
Jowett himself:
"I am the Reverend Benjamin Jowett.
All that's worth knowing, I know it;
I am the Master of Balliol College.
All that I don't know
is not knowledge."
Although Abolqasem longed
to be given one of the rooms
in his college, where he
could quietly devote himself
to his studies, his subsequent life
in Iran was anything but quiet.
He was given a number of assignments
after returning to Iran in 1883,
and following the death
of Mahmoud Khan,
he assumed his grandfather's
title of Naser ol-Molk,
and was nominated chief of the
Qaragozlou tribe - the last to be
so appointed by royal decree.
In 1888, Naser ed-Din
Shah undertook his third
and last journey to Europe.
Naser ol-Molk accompanied him
and had the task of interpreting
for the Shah, writing his speeches,
and organizing his
official engagements.
After Naser ed-Din
Shah was assassinated
in the Shah Abdol Azim mosque shrine
at Rey, Abolqasem Khan was sent
as roving ambassador, to all
the various Courts of Europe,
in order to announce the accession
of Mozaffar ed-Din Shah
to the throne in 1896.
And here is a photograph
of him in St. Petersburg.
He subsequently accompanied
the new Shah
on his first official
journey to Europe in 1900.
When they reached London,
the Cockney barrow-boys made
up a little rhyme to
commemorate the visit
of this exotic potentate:
"Have you seen the Shah?
Smoking his cigar.
Two black eyes, Forty wives,
Have you seen the Shah?
Growing public unrest
and dissatisfaction
with the Qajar Regime,
forced the reluctant Shah
to grant the country a
Constitution in 1906.
However, old and gravely ill with
renal failure, he died soon after,
and was succeeded by his
turbulent son Mohammad-Ali Mirza,
who was bitterly opposed to the
Constitution, but had to temporize
for a while in order to
assuage public disgust
with government by fiat.
Knowing that Naser ol-Molk
favoured constitutional government
and enjoyed the support of
the Majles, the Shah insisted
that he accept the
post of Prime Minister.
Not long after his nomination
however, the Shah ordered him
to bombard the upstart Majles,
which was cramping his liberty.
Abolghassem Khan reminded the
Shah that he had taken an oath
to do nothing against the
interests of the Crown,
and that he was convinced
such an arbitrary action was
against the interests of the Shah.
Instead of taking heed, the Shah
ordered him to obey or go to hell.
Naser ol-Molk replied that
under the circumstances,
he would prefer the latter,
and abruptly left the Court.
The following day, he was summoned
to Court and placed under arrest.
Indeed, it was intimated
that he might be put
to death for his defiance.
His carriage was sent away
with the ominous suggestion
that he would not be
needing it again.
His devoted coachman Mehdi Beyg
Sheverini was alarmed and hastened
to the British Legation, in
order to report the situation
to George Churchill,
the Oriental Secretary.
Mr. Churchill was away on a
shooting expedition at the time,
but Mehdi Beyg was
so acutely anxious
that he insisted upon
seeing Mrs. Churchill,
who promised to report the news to
her husband as soon as he returned.
Naser ol-Molk was confined
at the Golestan Palace
until well after dark.
He was offered coffee,
almost certainly poisoned
(the infamous Qajar coffee)
on several occasions but
was allowed to refuse.
Soon a threatening message was
brought to him from the Shah.
He replied that the Shah could
do with him whatever he wished,
but begged His Majesty to spare
him any personal indignities.
By nightfall, Churchill arrived
at the Palace still dressed
in his hunting clothes,
and requested an immediate
audience with the Shah.
He then informed him that he could
not be he could not be treated
in this arbitrary manner,
someone who had the highest
British decorations, the KCMG.
And that he shouldn't be
treated in this bad way.
Eventually, one of the courtiers,
Amir Bahador Jang, came to the room
where Naser ol-Molk was detained,
to tell him that His Majesty
had been gracious enough
to allow him leave to go to Europe.
He returned to the family home at
Sar Cheshmeh, where he was greeted
with transports of joy and relief.
At dawn the next day, he took a
ship for Baku and hence to Europe.
The Shah did bombard the Majles
after all, which resulted
in uprisings against him
throughout the country,
forcing him to seek refuge
at the Russian Legation.
He ignominiously abdicated in
favour of his son Ahmad Mirza,
the Crown Prince, who
was still a child.
Naser ol-Molk's name was put forward
by popular acclaim as Regent.
However, he was understandably
reluctant to return to Iran
and resume any kind
of political activity.
Under pressure from the Majles
Deputies, he did eventually return
and took up the Regency in 1910,
after much heart searching.
Immediately after the
coronation of Ahmad Shah in 914,
he definitively left active
political life and departed
for Europe once more
with his family.
He only returned to Iran
for the last time shortly before
his death in December 1927.
Reza Shah may not have
benefitted from a formal education,
and the opportunity to broaden
his mind through travel,
but he was blessed with even
more important attributes:
intelligence and common-sense.
He was conscious of his dependence
upon many of the most able grandees
of the Qajar era, and he made
use of them early in his reign.
Abolqasem Khan Naser ol-Molk
was accordingly invited
to lunch every Wednesday
for consultation,
and on one of these occasions,
Reza Shah had apparently
asked him what he considered
to be the most pressing
and significant reform he should
introduce among the myriad other
urgent matters he had to attend to.
In reply Abolqasem Khan had said:
"The creation of an
independent judiciary
to provide security
for the citizenry".
Advice which would be
highly relevant even today.
Abolqasem Khan married relatively
late in life, and Roqiyeh Khanom,
my maternal grandmother, was only
12 when she was betrothed to him.
Years later, while she was
visiting us in Washington,
where my father was Ambassador, she
used to say that as a young woman,
she traveled to Hamadan for the
summer months, in a 'kedjaveh'.
This was a diabolical
contraption resembling two small,
cushioned cubicles,
straddling the back of a mule.
The two ladies who were passengers,
naturally had to be well-matched
for weight, otherwise the
wretched mule would keel over!
The ladies travelled in a party
for one 'manzel' each day -
that is as far as a caravan
could travel in one day.
The attendants and cooks
rode on ahead to pitch tents,
prepare the dinner, and even to
create a little lawn in front
of the main tent, with turf they
rolled up and brought with them.
Yet here she was, thousands
of kilometers away in America,
having been transported there by
an airplane powered by thousands
of horsepower, rather than by the
single mule of her 'kedjaveh'!
My time is rapidly coming
to a close, but I cannot end
without some mention of
my father's crucial role
in the so-called Azarbaijan
Crisis of 1946.
So, we must travel fast-forward
in time to the early years
of World War II, when Reza Shah
was forced to abdicate in favour
of the Crown Prince Mohammad
Reza Pahlavi, under pressure
from the Allies, Britain
and the Soviet Union.
Iran was occupied by the
Allied Forces in August 1941.
Armaments and Lend Lease aid
to the hard-pressed
Soviets began immediately,
using Reza Shah's beloved railway
- the so-called Bridge of Victory.
At this point, the Iranian
government was in total disarray,
impotent economically and
politically, beset by hyperinflation
and famine, and unable to maintain
order among its rebellious tribes,
especially the Qashqai.
Over 300,000 refugees - mostly
Jews from Eastern European stetls,
were hospitably received by Iran
at this time, who were suffering
from the usual afflictions of war -
malnutrition, misery and infection,
especially louse-borne typhus,
which reached epidemic proportions,
and killed two of my Czechoslovakian
classmates at the Community School.
There was an acute shortage of wheat
because the Russians
had requisitioned grain.
Hoarding and black-marketeering
were rife.
I clearly remember being shown
an example of the coarse,
gray bread on sale in
bakeries, which contained bits
of tarred sacking, and even
the remains of a cockroach.
In breach of the 1942
Tripartite Agreement,
and the Tehran Conference
Declaration of 1943,
which Marshal Stalin had reluctantly
signed, guaranteeing the departure
of Allied Forces after the cessation
of hostilities, and the independence
and territorial integrity of Iran,
the Red Army stayed on in Azarbaijan
and Kordestan, fostering armed
insurrection by separatists -
Pishevari's Republic of Azarbaijan,
and Qazi Mohammad's
Free Kurdish Republic.
The Soviet NKVD dismantled
the administrative apparatus
of the Iranian government; Iranian
troops and gendarmes were disarmed;
landowners were dispossessed; judges
were arrested, and an Azari militia
in Russian uniforms
were armed and trained.
Protests by the Iranian government
were portrayed to the world
as a minor disagreement
between neighbours,
and the secessionist movements in
Azarbaijan and Kordestan were said
to represent the "legitimate
aspirations
of the down-trodden
peoples of these provinces,
for freedom and self-determination".
Hassan Taqizadeh, Iran's
Ambassador in London, and Ala,
now appointed by the new Prime
Minister Qavam os-Saltaneh,
as Ambassador to the United
States, and Iran's representative
at the new-found United Nations
Organization and Security Council,
realized that bilateral negotiation
with the Soviet Union
would not get anywhere,
particularly since Premier Qavam had
already spent three fruitless weeks
in Moscow, discussing
the issue with Stalin
and Molotov, the Foreign Minister.
The dispute had to
be internationalized,
if there was to be any hope of
success against Marshal Stalin,
who had already achieved most of
the post-war concessions he wanted
from the US and Britain, at the
Yalta and Potsdam Conferences.
In March 1946, Prime Minister Qavam
instructed Ala to prosecute the case
against the Soviet Union at
the UN Security Council..
His task was a difficult one:
First of all, 'Uncle Joe' Stalin,
as he was fondly known at the end
of the war, did everything he could
to prevent a hearing of Iran's
complaint at the international forum
of the fledgling Security Council.
Britain and the US, even
including Trygvie Lie,
the UN Secretary General,
were not inclined
to alienate the prestigious
victor of Stalingrad,
who had broken the back of the
Wehrmacht, and they were agnostic
about the chances of Iran
achieving any success.
Secondly, in Iran, Prime Minister
Qavam, was under intense pressure
from the new Soviet Ambassador
Satchikov, to withdraw the case
from the Security Council agenda,
and to sign an oil concession
with the USSR, giving
them exclusive rights
to exploit oil resources
in northern Iran.
However, despite the
prevarications of his cousin Qavam,
who actually contemplated
withdrawing Ala,
as well as the Security
Council case;
the intrigues of Qavam's Deputy
and spokesman Mozaffar Firouz,
and in the face of much bluster
and aggression from Gromyko,
the Soviet delegate, Ala was able to
marshal the support of the US media,
especially James Reston of the
New York Times, Harry Truman
and Secretary of State Jimmy
Byrnes, together with envoys
of smaller nations, who saw
this as a crucial issue,
involving the rights of weak
countries against a super-power,
and was finally given
the opportunity
of stating Iran's complaint
at the horse-shoe table
of the Security Council at
Hunter College in the Bronx,
and to passionately argue that the
continued presence of Soviet Forces
in northern Iran, constituted
a breach of their commitment,
and an immediate threat
to world peace.
In protest, Gromyko and his entire
delegation left the Security Council
in a huff - a red-letter day for
the assembled world press corps!
Although Ala was comprehensively
reprimanded for his persistence
by Prime Minister Qavam, and
accused by the Soviet delegate,
of exceeding his brief, and failing
to represent his government's true
instructions, Ala courageously
and relentlessly persevered in
pursuing the Iranian complaint,
which by then, had become an
international cause celebre.
In the end, Soviet forces did leave
northern Iran on May 6th, 1946,
and without the support
of the Red Army, the Azari
and Kurdish Republics collapsed.
The only occasion when the
Soviet Union ever released one
of the victims in its clutches.
As a consequence, the United
Nations Organization was immensely
strengthened by the peaceful
resolution of this first,
highly significant
case, it's first case,
but this also presaged the start
of a near fifty-year Cold War,
which persisted until the
USSR foundered in 1991,
essentially for economic reasons.
Now I hope Dr. Dinavari you were
able to show us a video clip,
dating back to March 1946.
Which had to be shortened,
I think it's after the Soviet
delegation stormed out.
[ Speaking in a Foreign Language ]
>> Mr. President, and honorable
members of the consult,
I consider it an honor to be
innovated to the counsel table.
It is I assure you with emotion
that I take my seat before
the highest tribunal on earth,
wherein lie the hopes and
aspirations of mankind.
I wish you success in your arduous
labor for the restoration of harmony
and security and respect
for international [inaudible]
in a destructive world.
Iran firmly believes in the
principles underlying the charter.
And [inaudible] to abide by them.
She has faced in the United
Nations and desires to the utmost
of her ability to strengthen
its hand.
She confidently expects
on the other hand
to have her rights
upheld by the consult.
Our case is down before you.
And we want it to remain there until
a just settlement has been reached
within the spirit of the charter.
I realize that the question
of whether to proceed at once
or the delay is a matter
for the counsel to decide.
For my part, I am prepared according
to my instructions to proceed
with the presentation
of the disputes
which unfortunately have divided by
country and its northern neighbor.
I consider it necessarily to do
so at the earliest opportunity.
Of course, I am not unaware of the
[inaudible] reporting [inaudible]
of the reb army from
certain [inaudible] of Iran.
In history, we heard the
same announcement made
by the honorable delegate
of the Soviet Union.
Nor am I unaware of the press news
of this morning reporting
an official announcement
by my government denying that
the [inaudible] activation
of troops had resulted from
any [inaudible] entered
into between the Iranian
government and the Soviet Union.
I do not know whether any conditions
are being attached to the withdrawal
of these troops and may I say once
for all that I know of no agreement
or understanding, secret or
otherwise, having been entered
into between my government and the
Soviet Union with respect to any
of the matters involved
in the disputes now
referred to this counsel.
No one would welcome more warmly
than a just settlement
of our difficult case.
On the basis of respect for Iran's
complete independence, sovereignty,
and territorial integrity.
The prime minister of Iran
has in his instructions to me,
particularly requested me
to emphasize the [inaudible]
that the bringing of a
dispute by one member
of the United Nations before the
security council should not be
interpreted by the other
party as an [inaudible] act.
We are members of the same family
is this is a sort of family counsel
where we can freely air our troubles
and reach satisfaction [inaudible].
The delegate of the Soviet Union
bases his proposal for delay first
on alleged [inaudible] and
second on the continuation
that negations [inaudible] of
the resolution of January 30th.
>> Yes. And by the
way, the person glaring
at my father there was Oskar Lange,
the representative of Poland,
who gave him a really hard time and
of course Poland was already one
of the satellite countries
of the Soviet Union by then.
There's one more, sorry.
Oh.
>> My apologies.
>> And the next--
>> I'm just going to
go, hold on one second.
From here?
>> Yes.
>> Let me try and slide-- wah-la.
>> Yes, I mean this is actually my
last slide, you'll be happy to hear.
And showing Bessie Truman,
Harry Truman, the young Shah,
and my father on the right who
was still ambassador of Iran.
And really culminating
the happy resolution
of the Azerbaijan Crisis was
president Truman's formal invitation
extended to the youthful
[inaudible] Shah [inaudible] of Iran
to visit the USA in 1949.
His very first trip
to the United States.
By some happy chance, the
son of counsel retained
by the Iranian delegation to advice
them in conducting this crucial case
against the Soviet Union was
the father of David Leland,
who is sitting here
in the front row.
And I'm so happy that
he's been able to be here.
John Leland was a very
distinguished international lawyer
who might have become
Secretary of State expect
that he was a bit brusque
to his critics.
And so that never happened.
But he was a great family
friend as his children were.
Thank you very much
for your attention.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, thank you so much.
And I know we are running
out of time.
But I think we will
leave the session as is.
I think it was a wonderful
covering of the events
and a very important part
of the history of Iran.
And I want to thank
you all for being here
and for having come joined us today.
So again, let us thank Dr.
Ala for all he has done.
And I hope, I hope with have
a chance to see him again
and see his wonderful wife who has
been a partner in all this project
and for all of us, thank you.
>> There was one more slide.
>> Yes, please show it.
>> The very last one.
Yes, this is really, my
wife and I at [inaudible].
And of course I owe
my thanks to my wife
who is the great archivist
in the family, actually.
So. Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.